right
so for example here's an example of a
thing that i realized
so one of the surprising things about
well the two surprising facts about math
one is that it's hard and the other is
that it's doable
okay so first question is why is math
hard you know you've got these axioms
they're very small
why can't you just solve every problem
in math easily yeah it's just logic
right right yeah well logic happens to
be a particular special case that does
have certain simplicity to it
but general mathematics even arithmetic
already doesn't have the simplicity that
logic has
so why is it hard because of
computational irreducibility
right because what happens is
to know what's true and this is this
whole story about the path you have to
follow and how long is the path
and girdle's theorem is the statement
there could be an inf that the path is
not a bounded length
but the fact that the path is not always
compressible to something tiny
is a story of computational
irreducibility so that's that's why math
is hard
now the next question is why is math
doable because it might be the case that
most things you care about don't have
finite length paths
most things you care about might be
things where you get lost
in the sea of computational
irreducibility and
worse undecidability that is there's
just no
finite length path that gets you there
um you know
why is mathematics doable you know godel
proved his incompleteness theorem in
1931
most working mathematicians don't really
care about it they just go ahead and do
mathematics
even though it could be that the
questions they're asking are undecidable
it could have been that fermat's last
theorem is undecidable it turned out
it had a proof it's a long complicated
proof the twin prime conjecture might be
undecidable
the riemann hypothesis might be
undecidable these things
might be the axioms of mathematics might
not be
strong enough to reach those statements
it might be the case that
depending on what axioms you choose you
can either say that's true or that's not
true
so and and by the way from as last
theorem there could be a shorter path
absolutely yeah so that the notion of
gd6 in mata mathematical space is the
notion of shortest proofs
in meta mathematical space and that's a
you know human mathematicians do not
find shortest paths
nor do automated theorem provers um but
the fact
and and by the way the i mean this stuff
is so bizarrely connected i mean
if you if you're into automated theorem
proving there are these so-called
critical pair lemmas and automated
theorem proving
those are precisely the branch pairs in
our
um that in multi-way graphs let me just
finish on the why mathematics is doable
oh yes the second part so right you know
why it's hard why is it doable
right why do we not just get lost in
undecidability all the time yeah
um so and here's another fact
is in doing computer experiments and
doing experimental mathematics you do
get lost in that way
when you just say i'm picking a random
integer equation how do i does it have a
solution or not
and you just pick it at random without
any human sort of
path getting there often it's really
really hard
it's really hard to answer those
questions we just pick them up random
from the space of possibilities
but what's what i think is happening is
and that's a case where you just
fell off into this ocean of sort of
irreducibility and so on
what's happening is human mathematics is
a story of building a path
you you started off you're always
building out
on this path where you are proving
things you you've got this proof
trajectory
and you're basically the human
mathematics is this sort of
the exploration of the world along this
proof
trajectory so to speak you're not you're
not just you know
uh parachuting in from from you know
from from anywhere
you're following you know lewis and
clark or whatever you're actually you're
actually going
doing the path and the fact that you are
constrained to go along that path
is the reason you don't end up with like
every so often you'll see a little piece
of undecidability and you'll avoid that
that part of the path but that's
basically the story of why
human mathematics has seemed to be
doable it's a story of exploring these
paths
that that are by their nature they have
been constructed
to be parts that can be followed and so
you can follow them further
now you know what why is this relevant
to anything so okay so here's the
the my my my belief the fact that human
mathematics works that way
is i think there's some sort of
connections between the way that
observers work in physics and the way
that the axiom systems and mathematics
are set up
to make mathematics be doable in that
kind of way
and so in other words in particular i
think there is an analog of causal and
variance
which i think is um and this is again
it's sort of the upper reaches of
mathematics and and stuff that um
uh it's a thing there's this thing
called homotopy type theory
which is an abstract it's came out of
category theory
and it's sort of an abstraction of
mathematics mathematics itself is an
abstraction
but it's an abstraction of the
abstraction of mathematics
and there is the thing called the
univalence axiom which is a
sort of a a a a key axiom in that
set of ideas and i'm pretty sure the
univalence axiom is equivalent to causal
invariance
what was the term used again you know
univalence is that something for
somebody like me accessible
um or is this there's a statement of it
that's fairly accessible
i mean the statement of it is um uh
basically it says things which are
equivalent can be considered
to be identical in
but in which space yeah it's it's an in
higher category
okay in category okay so it's a it's a
but i mean the thing just to give a
sketch of how that works so category
theory
is an attempt to idealize it's an
attempt to
sort of have a formal theory of
mathematics that is at a sort of higher
level than
mathematics it's where where you just
think think about these mathematical
objects
and these categories of objects and
these these
morphisms these connections between
categories okay so it turns out the
morphisms and categories
at least weak categories are very much
like the paths and our hypographs and
things
and it turns out again this is this is
where it all gets
gets crazy i mean it's it's the fact
that these things are connected it's
just bizarre
so category theory uh the
our causal graphs are like second order
category theory
and it turns out you can take the limits
of infinite order category theory so
just give roughly the idea this is a
this is a
roughly explainable idea so a
mathematical proof
will be a path that says you can get
from this thing to this other thing and
here's the path you get from this thing
to this other thing
but in general there may be many paths
many proofs
that get you many different paths that
all successfully go from this thing to
this other thing
okay now you can define a higher order
proof
which is a proof of the equivalence of
those proofs
okay so you're saying there's a path
between those proofs essentially
yes a path between the paths yeah okay
and so you do that that's the sort of
second order thing that path between the
pars
is essentially related to our causal
graphs
wow okay path between paths between
parts between path
the infinite limit that infinite limit
turns out to be our ruling multi-way
system
yeah the royal the the ruling multi-way
system that's a fascinating thing
both in the physics world and and as
you're saying that yeah yeah that's
that's fine so i'm not sure i've loaded
it all in completely but well i'm not
sure i have either and it may be one of
these things where
where you know in another another five
years or something it's like
this was obvious but i didn't see it now
but the thing which is sort of
interesting to me is that there's
sort of an upper reach of of mathematics
of the abstraction of mathematics
um this thing there's this mathematician
called growth and deek who's generally
viewed as being sort of one of the most
abstract sort of creator of the most
abstract mathematics of
1970s ish time frame um
and one of the things that he
constructed was this thing he called the
infinity groupoid
um and he has this sort of hypothesis
about the inevitable appearance of
geometry
from essentially logic in the structure
of this thing
well it turns out this real multi-way
system is the infinity group void
so it's a it's this limiting object and
this
is an this is an instance of that
limiting object
so what to me is i mean again i i've
been always afraid of this kind of
mathematics because it seemed
incomprehensibly abstract to me um but
what's
what's what i'm sort of excited about
with this is that
that we've sort of concretified the way
that you can reach this kind of
mathematics
which makes it uh well both seem more
relevant and also
the fact that that you know i don't yet
know exactly what mileage we're going to
get from using
the sort of the apparatus that's been
built in those areas of mathematics
to analyze what we're doing but the
thing that's uh so both ways so using
the mathematics understand what you're
doing and using
right so you're doing computationally to
understand that right so for example the
the understanding of
uh meta-mathematical space one of the
reasons i really want to do that
is because i want to understand quantum
mechanics better and and
that what you see you know we live
that uh kind of the multi-way graph of
mathematics because we actually know
this is a theorem we've heard of this is
another one we've heard of
we can actually say these are actual
things in the world that we
relate to which we can't really do as as
readily
for the the physics case and so it's
kind of a way to help my intuition it's
also
you know there are bizarre things like
the what's the analog of einstein's
equations in meta-mathematical space
what's the analog of a black hole you
know it turns out it looks like
not completely sure yet but there's this
notion of non-constructive proofs in
mathematics
and i think those relate to well
actually the the
they're they relate to things and
related to event horizons um so the fact
that you can take
ideas from physics like event horizons
and map them into the same kind of place
it's it's really do you think there'll
be do you think you might stumble
upon some breakthrough ideas in theory
improving
like for from the the other direction
yeah yeah yeah no i mean
what's really nice is that we are using
so this
this absolutely directly maps to their
improving so paths and multi-way graphs
that's what a theorem
is trying to but i also mean like like
automated theorem yeah yeah
that's what right so the finding of pods
the finding of shortest paths or finding
a path at all
is what automated theorem approvers do
and actually what
what we've been doing so we've you know
we've actually been using automated
theorem proving both in the physics
project to prove things
and using that as a way to understand
multi-way graphs
and because what an automated theorem
prover is doing
is it's trying to find a path through a
multi-way graph
and it's critical pair lemmas are
precisely little
stubs of branch pairs going off into
branch hill space
and that's i mean it's really weird you
know we have these visualizations in
welfare language of
our of of um proof graphs from our
automatic theorem proving system
and they look reminiscent of well it's
just bizarre because we made these up a
few years ago yeah and they have these
little triangle things
and they're they are we didn't quite get
it right we didn't quite get the analogy
perfectly right but it's very close
you